[Música]
el cementerio de la paz es la última
morada de más de 100.000 fallecidos pero
ya se acaba el espacio de 450 entierros
mensuales en tiempo normal paso a 2.150
en julio cuando la ciudad enfrentó el
pico de la pandemia de kobe hemos tenido
dos mil 150 servicios aproximadamente de
los cuales 250 han sido cremaciones y
con un 1900
servicios de entierro entonces en cuanto
a la capacidad del cementerio hemos
podido atender este pico ante la falta
de espacio la alcaldía buscó un terreno
para construir un nuevo camposanto cerca
del barrio paceño de pura pura pero los
vecinos del lugar se oponen ellos
aseguran que el terreno elegido debe ser
parte de un bosquecillo en lugar de un
cementerio que pegan otras posibilidades
no somos gente indolente nosotros
también hemos pasado en esa situación
del tema del cobi y la necesidad de
donde nuestros familiares vamos a llevar
la incineración de cadáveres en bolivia
creció durante la pandemia ante el
desborde de las muertes por eso unos
empresarios inventaron crematorios
portátiles de 2.7 toneladas su coste es
de 45 mil dólares y se han vendido media
docena a igual número de municipios es
una alternativa que se hemos puesto a
bolivia y al mundo para poder ayudar en
lo que es trasladar el horno de disc a
distintos lugares y poder brindar el
servicio según el gobierno por causa de
la pandemia murieron más de 5 mil
personas sin embargo los análisis
independientes señalan que sólo hasta
fines de julio había un exceso de 14.000
muertes atribuibles al coronavirus unas
muertes que necesitan sepulturas dignas